- [Narrator] During the
2008 presidential campaign,
Michelle Obama was asked
on "The Tonight Show"
about the cost of her wardrobe.
- [Jay] 60, 70,000 for that outfit?
- Actually, this is a J. Crew ensemble.
- Really, wow.
- [Narrator] J. Crew clothing
would become a staple
in the former first lady's wardrobe,
elevating the brand's
image from preppy basics
to professional, yet
affordable chic, but recently,
the apparel brand has
struggled with slumping sales
and a debt load that
ultimately led the retailer
to seek bankruptcy protection.
In court filings, the
company cited losses incurred
because of coronavirus lockdowns,
but analysts say the brand
also lost touch with consumers
with styles that appeared more suited
for the runway than for everyday life.
Here's how J. Crew filed for bankruptcy.
J. Crew, formerly known as
Popular Merchandise, Inc.,
emerged in 1983 as a
catalog-only retailer.
It offered a pioneering
line of casual fashion
built on affordable weathered chinos
and simple crew neck t-shirts.
- Well, they were really
the preppy chic brand,
sort of preppy with a twist,
the kind of clothes that, you know,
you could wear to the office,
but also the perfect weekend clothes.
- [Narrator] The brand opened its first
retail store in 1989,
and over the next decade,
found its home in malls
across the country.
Many of the brand's styles can
be attributed to Jenna Lyons
who was first hired as a designer in 1990.
Her design influence grew
the brand by attracting both
luxury and middle-class customers.
Former Gap CEO Mickey Drexler
joined the company in 2003
and promoted Lyons to creative
director a few years later.
- Mickey Drexler was best
known for turning Gap
into a cultural icon in the 1990s.
He came to J. Crew and
sort of had a second act,
and Jenna Lyons was sort of his creative
right-hand woman, so to speak,
to turn things like sequins
which you would think
were that you'd only were sort
of out on a Saturday night.
All of a sudden, you could
wear them during the day,
and she kind of really
glammed up the brand.
- [Narrator] In 2006, Drexler founded
the successful companion brand Madewell.
J. Crew also with public that same year
only to be taken private
again five years later
in a leveraged buyout that
saddled the company with debt.
Not too long after, sales began to flag.
Starting in 2014, J. Crew
experienced six straight years
of losses, and the company
started looking for ways
to cut back and attract new customers.
- Well, they started
to get a bit too glam,
and this is where some of the critics
started blaming Jenna, that
her style became too Brooklyn
for their kind of J. Crew's
mainstream customers,
and then on top of that,
they ended up with
quality and fit problems.
The quality became inconsistent.
Customers kind of just
lost faith in the brand.
- [Narrator] In 2017 with the
company still floundering,
Lyons departed, and Drexler
stepped down as CEO,
and the brand narrowly
avoided bankruptcy as part of
a controversial debt swap that moved
its intellectual property
beyond the reach of creditors.
- They were just caught
a little bit flat-footed
and didn't act fast enough to, you know,
develop e-commerce, to
develop all the things now
that we sort of expect from a retailer.
- [Narrator] Heading into 2020,
J. Crew planned to raise
cash by spinning off
its Madewell chain through an IPO,
but plans came to a halt
as coronavirus lockdowns
forced the retailer to
close some 500 stores.
In court filings, the brand
said it expected to lose
$900 million in sales because of lockdowns
putting it in a position where
it couldn't pay its debts.
On May 4th, 2020 J. Crew
filed for bankruptcy.
- You know, J. Crew
has a smaller footprint
than a lot of other retailers,
and they didn't overexpand,
so that's a positive for them.
They are in a position where
they're not gonna probably
have to close hundreds of stores,
and they also have a
new CEO, and you know,
her mission was sort
of to restore the brand
to its former glory,
getting back to the quality
and the fit that the customers loved
and kind of the classic styles.
- [Narrator] As the retailer
looks to navigate its way
out of bankruptcy, it will
also try to recapture customers
who once looked for
clothes that could be worn
on any occasion, even inauguration day.
(people cheering)
(anxious music)